americans invested more money in the
past five months than they did in the
last 12
years this is a fortune story over the
past five months over a half a trillion
dollars
has flowed into equity funds according
to a report from bank of america that's
more than
that's more than the past 12 years
combined there are a number of reasons
for the surging investments individual
investors have been
especially active as stocks like
gamestop amc
have been have seen big surges this year
thanks to
reddit's wall street bets community and
overall optimism about the pandemic has
been on the rise
since early november 2020 when pfizer
first reported
that trials on cover 19vx and showed it
was 90 effective
the market themselves have have been
helping
spur investment enthusiasm as well the s
p is now up 17
the past five months nasdaq composite is
up 27
the dow jones is up 27 approximately 569
billion
has gone to global equity since november
in the previous 12 months combined the
total was just
452 billion dollars thoughts yeah the
the
um the numbers are here we're gonna have
to break down some of these numbers
but just put yourself in the shoes of
the common investor
right especially younger people who
you're sitting at home
you're getting stimulus check after
stimulus check after stimulus check
there's been what three rounds of
stimulus checks
and there's been what five trillion
dollars pumped into the
pr into the u.s economy yep printed i
learned digitally not even necessarily
real um hard cash and you're sitting at
home you got nowhere to go you got
nothing to do
some people are going to maybe fix up
their houses but if you're a renter or
if you're just like looking to get
involved in the market where else are
you going to go
so traditionally 55 of americans have
invested in the stock market 80 percent
of americans have debt
so they're looking at the the the key to
this article is over the last
five months versus the last 12 years
yeah five months versus 12 years that's
right
so it's 140 billion dollars more
in the last five months than the last
four people understand how much a
trillion is
people don't understand how much a
trillion is i actually
i actually ironically spoke with ted
koppel one time
after a nalba event ironically and he
started talking about the word the
trillion he said and he gave the analogy
if you go into if you went into business
with jesus your boy your main man
you went into business with jesus two
thousand and
twenty something years ago and you guys
made a million dollars a day a million
dollars a day
you wouldn't even made a trillion
dollars do some quick math for me
220 times a million is what 220
million or yeah well we said if you made
a million dollars a day for the
million dollars a day yeah what is that
number well no you got to do a million a
day
times 365 which is 365 million 365
million times 2 000
i think it's a trillion a little under a
trillion
point point that i'm getting do some
fact check call out ted koppel right now
yeah no ted cobb was smart
point is if you wanted the business of
jesus you made a million bucks a day for
the last 2000 years it wouldn't even be
a trillion
so you got some math for me he's
actually right 730 billion okay that's
my
point 738 so if you and jesus get into
business
a million dollars every day 730 billion
so you don't even make a trillion so now
you're talking about infusing
five freaking trillion dollars into the
economy
and you're just sitting at home nothing
to do you hear things like
buy the dip because clearly it dipped a
year ago now the market's making a
comeback yep
you know bonds are paying nothing cash
is paying nothing um
the so what else you gonna do with your
money you have elon musk i think
half of all people invested their money
based on an elon musk tweet like all
these ridiculous stats
here's the challenge though because
obviously i'm a big fan of the stock
market it's amazing it's
awesome it's awesome but we're talking
over the last five months so all these
new investors potentially
know is up yup that all they know is the
rocket ship that's been going to the
moon
what happens when the bubble bursts and
you know the market goes down what
happens well i think the average
so the average consumer the average joe
in the street middle class is now
seeing hey i can join the party and
there's a lot of buzz come join the
party the water's fine
the the market's up and they've got
reddit and it's happening to them on
mainstream
uh mainstreet bats but also in the
social media is hitting them on facebook
it's hitting robin hood oh robin hood
it's so easy
just click here click here click here
open yourself a little account so i
think there's a name
number one there's a lot of buzz number
two there's enablers making it easy they
can just open up a robinhood account and
they can do it connect their checking
account
bang done it did not used to be that
easy even open america eight account
remember that
it was not easy just to move even 500
bucks to start that so
now it's very easy there's a lot of
enablers there's a lot of buzz going out
there and people have the perception
that it's up up up and they don't
realize the ups and downs
and you know they're they've got time on
their hands
and i also think what's happening
investment is i think a reaction to
what they saw happening so i'm wondering
if also in middle class america
they're thinking maybe i do need to
think a little bit for myself here and
do a little bit of this
because last year my cousin was in real
estate that sucked my other cousin was
in
with cruise ships that was terrible you
know i think that there's
i think that there's also some like
maybe i need to do something here but a
lot of enablers and a lot of buzz
you know you know one time i read a book
called ageless man
okay ageless man so this guy who's a pro
steroids guy
pretty crazy story i'm about to tell you
right now pro series guys it's a
hardcore steroids guys like listen you
got to take steroids
like i got to take steroids i'm telling
you as you age you got to take steroids
but before you take it read this book
ageless man so i go buy this book and i
start reading it ageless man
and his argument was based on studies
they did on rats or whatever you know
it's real like studies they did on it in
the book i mean it could be making it up
but in the book i'm reading that they
did studies
that folks whose testosterone level
drops
you die younger than those whose
testosterone level is higher
okay so you're looking at like okay
grants oh well this person does steroids
that person does growth hormone this
person does this and
nowadays there's the movement of doing
what trt and taking a little bit of uh
you know gh not the real big you know
the whole gh but
slight gh right okay
who's right on the argument okay are the
arguments towards
steroids are good or steroids are bad
historically we've been told stories are
what
bad for you right growth hormone is what
bad for you
in some cases growth hormones worked for
many kids in some cases
steroids have worked for older people a
lot of times you'll see a 75
year old saying hey what happened to you
i just went to the doctor today they
gave me a shot of what
a steroid shot what steroid shot right
okay you're gonna see where i'm going
with this
um you know the consequences of
being raised in a great community or bad
community
the price of going to private school
kids become drug addicts more at private
schools than they do public schools all
these different data that we get right
hey you know
if you spoil them if you love them too
much if you discipline too much just
side effects of this okay
we have no clue what the side effects
are of giving people five trillion
dollars
of funding we don't know there is no
market research on this
we can't go look at anywhere and say
here's what happens so
everything we're experiencing today is
out of whack you don't know what your
body is reacting to today
so you can't sit there and say this is
real this is fake this is this so i'll
tell to people
this is fake money so give the argument
this is fake money they'll say well you
know according to
what we're looking at right now nothing
has shown the fact that printing money
and putting money into the
economy is a bad thing nothing some
experts will even say that
well okay so if that's the case why
don't we keep
giving everybody a trillion dollars
every six months
if it's so great give everybody a
trillion dollars every six months
let's just fund it and see what happens
forget about people working let's just
keep
giving people money they're gonna invest
into the stock market so if they invest
into stock market
who's gonna work at amazon for forty
five thousand dollars a year
if we're giving them money who's gonna
have a job so there has to be a part
where people realize
fake kind of success like this where
people invest
more in five months than 12 years you
can
in the world of sales like i run a sales
company
if one of your guys all of a sudden is
used to doing
pick a number a hundred thousand dollars
a month and for the last three years
he's always at 100 000 a month and he
grows every year
at a rate of twelve percent so it's
nothing crazy
he grows at six to twelve percent the
sales guy he used to do a hundred
thousand now he's doing a hundred ten
thousand hundred twenty thousand a month
but it's generally around a hundred
thousand dollar number
all of a sudden he goes from a hundred
thousand like if you're talking about
five months
12 years that's what that's 24 times 25
times more if you really break it down
per month right like if you take down
569 billion dollars let's let's actually
do the math on this
kai do me a favor and divide 452
divide that by uh 120 months divide that
by 120 months okay i'm gonna do 569
divided by five months
how much 452 divided by 120 months
actually
12 times 244 months
okay here's here's the crazy number how
much
3.1 here's a crazy number you ready this
is the number
it says 569 billion have gone into
equities in the last how many months
five months you divided by five what's
the number 113.8
okay you then it says what 452 billion
dollars in the last what
12 years how many months in a year 12.
12 times 12 is what 144.
you take 452 billion and you divided by
144 on how much went into equities every
month
3.1 we went from 3.1 billion a month
to talking about 113.8 bill
so so if you actually break that down
that's like a sales guy going from doing
a hundred thousand dollars a month
let's do 113 divided by three is what
that's like a guy going from doing a
hundred thousand dollars a month
all of a sudden he's doing 3.7 million
dollars a month that's crazy
that's crazy so you can't just sit oh my
gosh he's killing it great job what a
fantastic job
he must be doing good you have to be
naive if you don't investigate and say
what the hell is going on here there's
got to be some
so there's two reactions to it there's
almost do you notice a
level of panic with people like oh my
gosh i better get my
hands on the money that's being made uh
coinbase oh bitcoins
nft oh my gosh it's like it's like this
this anxiety is creating in everybody
sure
okay you know what that's gonna do that
same anxiety and rush when you take
drugs when you take too much coffee when
you drink too much alcohol
when you are too much and you get off
you know what happens it's called the
crash
now forget the market crash it's called
a crash within yourself
how is how is crash feel after you have
12 glass of you know
12 cups of coffee how is crash feel
after you get off some kind of drugs or
alcohol what's the crash feel like
and i'm talking about like a heavy duty
crush i'm not talking about like a
you know a a light crash i'm talking
about like a real crash
yep it's extreme you're like you're
lethargic you can't even get out my
concern is
the crash is going to create the kind of
lethargic that we've not seen before
i hope i'm wrong but there is no
mathematical evidence that this works
i can't get it there is no mathematical
evidence that this
is good to sit there and say fantastic
how awesome is that you know your kid is
used to getting seven hours of sleep all
of a sudden your kid is going on two
hours of sleep for two straight weeks
and you sit there and you don't do
anything with it you think it's normal
you have issues right if your kid is
going out there and you're like wait
what's going the other night tycho great
crazy story
tico never goes to sleep early ever to
the others like
um i'm gonna go to bed early like what
so i'm going to bed early you're not
going to bed early so now i just want to
go to bed early i'm tired
so i go to jan jen's like babe tico
never goes to bed early
is something okay with him i said i
don't know let me go see
i go to his room okay he's under his
sheets
okay he's nine so he's not under his
sheets at 14. he's under her sheets at
nine okay
so look to see what he's up to he's got
the ipad under the sheets i'm like okay
you don't wonder you're going to bed
early
you don't ever go to bed early he
figured out a way to get that ipad
upstairs and he's playing a little bit
of video games because i had to get the
last
uh what do you call it when the game you
got to get a screen out of a
a um skin i had to get that skin i said
what is the skin he says
it's like an nf do you have to get that
skin for this game i'm like you
literally when i took the ipad came
upstairs he says yeah
so you have to study trends there is
something
very suspicious about the way the
numbers are growing and people cannot
sit there and say
this is real you better have some puts
you better have some defensive strategy
here
you better be ready that if the market
hits
and hits the fan what is defensive
what is defensive
okay defensive is gold defensive is the
complete opposite of what everybody else
is doing today
you just got to be ready today because
this to me doesn't feel real anyways
i could be wrong i'm speculating but
none of this stuff makes any sense to me
well number one kudos
to tico for going to bed early number
two um
by the way we all just got a glimpse of
pat's beautiful mind when it comes to
math that was freaking ridiculous i'm
still trying to
like put a hundred billion basic
calculators nothing i did was calculate
that was kind of ridiculous
no no no it's just no no he he he
it's called the perspective effect i
know you're a rocket scientist so for us
you know regular folks
son of a rocket scientist right son of a
rocket scientist literally
this son of a rock is it but um my major
point here is this
and you brought up a great point there's
so much stuff going on right now
coinbase ipo
and the spac and the nfts and the
markets up in the fight it's just like
what you need to do if you're home
listening is just find your center of
gravity
yeah and not compare yourself to
everyone else that's doing all this
and the winklevoss twins are making 10
trillion dollars and the guy down the
street my uber driver he's now a little
crypto billionaire it's like
just figure out your situation you know
like we talked about last time
you know crazy numbers of people are
paying off debt
that's awesome right pay off your debt
save that money start getting invested
but have you know
defense in place and just find your
center of gravity because there's so
much nonsense going out there
it's so easy to get swept up with all
the chaos and the momentum that's going
on
like you said the crash is inevitable
whether it's within yourself or whether
it's the market
and just find your balance so you're not
what you just said there's only evidence
of the front half
to pat's point there's no evidence of
the back half about the responsibility
setting aside what you've earned on the
investments and being responsible and
prepared for the dark side
there's plenty of evidence what we just
talked about on the front side wow i got
some money some stimulus check what was
it
two weeks ago government said that the
millennials and uh
some of the um older zs were actually
investing their stimulus checks
you know because they still had their
job it was a white-collar job it was an
industry wasn't very much affected they
still had their job
so that they well guess what here's some
free money with the government you know
what
you used to get a free toaster when you
opened up a
a checking account at suntrust bank in
miami
now they put now this is like the
government saying well here's a
brokerage account and here's
almost two thousand dollars go for it
and you brought up a good point
the gamification of stocks with robin
hood
yeah you know someone says happy
birthday on your iphone and you get all
the confetti or congratulations
have you noticed that robin hood i went
and i checked it out robin hood
it does that you have all this stuff
it's yeah anybody seen robin hood that
when you make a uh
a trade or something on robin hood they
give you there's this the screen effect
and so it's almost like they've turned
something that's very serious that
requires the level of caution
into what feels like a game yeah and
with some of uncle sam's money that was
free
so so you know the whole thing with uh
save your money save your money save
your money cash just can't cash this
game can you save that money yeah
no of course save that money catch this
king and i'm a big proponent of that
but i'm also not for right now uh uh i'm
also
even for the the the investor that's a
smaller investor you put a little bit of
in in
stuff that cannot be reprinted you know
in the last couple years i've put i
don't know nearly five million dollars
into cards
okay yeah i mean what i mean everyday
cards are coming over here right now and
not just baseball cards not just
basketball
in maryland i got and
the most crazy cars that come in here
right now two weeks ago we had all the
uh
all the 50s the glamour golden years of
hollywood
that's the card yesterday i got some
very weird cards that came in but i set
them aside right
why it cannot be reprinted folks pay
very close attention to whatever can be
reprinted at any point
decision made by the government that's
your competitor your competitor says i'm
going to reprint
money that's pathetic if you can reprint
money
it's like saying anybody can reprint the
1986 flea or michael jordan and hey flir
says
we're going to reprint 10 million of the
cards
out of those 10 million out of cards
right now there's only 315 of them give
or take
graded psa 10. you get 3 100 of them
created a psa 10. that card goes from
350 000 card 400 000 card
to 50 000 card so it's the reason why
ken griffey's card rookie upper deck
1989 is now worth 300 000
because there is a couple thousand of
them psa 10. it doesn't carry the same
weight
whatever that gold cannot be reprinted
cards cannot be reprinted
unique art cannot be reprinted we read
this with the article the other day from
bank of america the merrill lynch guy
remember the merrill lynch guy that we
read about
start pay a literal attention to that
because it
can not be reprinted so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]